[Music]
with a mountain national chorus to crime
police brutality against black Americans
there's a new call for deep structural
reform of policing across the country in
the wake of the George Floyd killing at
the hands of law enforcement calls for
defunding and demilitarizing the police
are gaining momentum in cities like
Minneapolis where Floyd died under the
Neva policemen officials are discussing
moving funds from police departments
into health care mental health and other
community programs new york city's
budget received unprecedented attention
when protesters camped out in front of
city hall ahead of the deadline to
demand 1 billion in cuts to the NYPD's
5.9 billion dollar budget public
protests continue to put pressure on
cities to slash police budgets raising
the question how did America's Police
Department's acquire so much in funding
in the first place
a quick look at the history of policing
after reconstruction the slate Patrol is
morphed into local police departments
determined to enforce Jim Crow laws to
control black people police unions
really began consolidating power in the
1950s in response to activists pushing
for police reform fighting against
oversight and advocating fiercely for
their own ranks
they developed strict rules that remain
in place for most police forces today
police power continued to expand after
the 1960s civil rights movement
the 1965 law enforcement assistant act
part of President Johnson's
administration's war on crime paved the
way for militarization and funding by
increasing federal involvement in local
policing through grants the support for
local law enforcement from the federal
government continued to grow with a
series of laws passed under subsequent
presidents from Reagan to Trump that
further aligned police departments with
the military and perpetuated funding
according to FBI statistics the
country's violent crime rate has fallen
by half since 1993 somewhat in part to
an officer hiring surge in the 90s paid
for by the federal government which had
a modest downward effect on crime during
that decade in the 1990s violent
policing of communities of color
escalated as part of a theory known as
broken windows the theory states that
signs of disorder and vandalism in a
neighborhood lead to more serious
criminal activity it gave police a
reason to crack down on misdemeanors and
led to NYC's infamous stop and frisk
policy since the early 90s more than
seven billion dollars worth of excess US
military equipment has been transferred
from the Department of Defense to
federal state and local law enforcement
agencies free of charge as part of its
1033 program grants and programs like
this have seemingly given some
departments the arab armed paramilitary
regiments instead of friendly
neighborhood patrols
another results of police militarization
is the rise of special weapons and
tactics teams and so-called no-knock
raids in search of illegal drugs police
SWAT raids jumped from 3,000 a year in
the early 1980s to 45,000 by 2007
rallies across this country they are
shouting another name as well Brianna
Taylor in March Brianna Taylor whose
name has also become a rallying cry for
black lives matter activists was killed
by Louisville Kentucky police who
entered her apartment with a no-knock
warrant meanwhile between 1993 and 2017
the average spending on policing by the
nation's 150 largest cities grew 42%
after the grant money ran out in 2000
and the hiring push slowed the impact on
crime remains low yet by 2017 state and
local government spending on police
reached one hundred and fifteen billion
dollars so how exactly are these growing
police budgets being spent
salaries are by far the biggest line
items on the budget accounting for at
least two-thirds of police budgets
nationally with overtime and benefits
included personnel expenditures could
account for as much as 90 percent of
police budgets proponents of the
movement to defund police departments
would like to see money redirected to
community services like schools housing
social services and health programs as
funding for social safety net programs
has decreased over the years police
officers are being called to situations
they are ill-equipped to handle this
includes calls involving the homeless
people with mental illness and drug
addictions the average Police Department
spends 168 hours training new recruits
on firearms self-defense and the use of
force tactics according to a 2013
Justice Department report the department
spends just nine hours on conflict
management and mediation
police unions increasingly have taken a
more central role within departments
police compensation has grown in
lockstep with the power of police unions
it's not just salary and Pensions they
negotiate increasingly the unions help
advocate for the rights of officers
facing discipline many experts say that
unions have played a leading role in
blocking reform efforts and shielding
officers from punishment for misconduct
in the end even if activists fail in
their efforts to restructure policing
law enforcement budgets still aren't
safe from cuts due to the Cova 19
pandemic state budgets are headed for a
loss of 615 billion dollars over the
next three years according to the Center
on Budget and Policy Priorities and that
figure doesn't include the hit that
local and municipal governments will
take especially since they rely so
heavily on state governments for funding
so while President Trump himself has
said there will be no defunding of
police his refusal thus far to help
state and local governments may actually
force the cuts
[Music]